if you want to be rich you can't hang
out with poor people if you want to be
healthy and fit you can't hang around
with people that aren't healthy and fit
you always become the average of the
people you spend the most time with stop
hanging around certain people stop doing
certain things that you've been
comfortable doing right the definition
of insanity doing the same thing over
and over again trying to get a different
result but you're continuing to do the
same thing over and over again you never
get that different result surround
yourself with the same losers that got
you to where you're at are not going to
get you to where you want to go one of
the other issues that many of you guys
fall into is you is you limit this to oh
I'm gonna save it for New Year's why why
do you have to wait for a specific date
to do something about something of [__]
in your life guess what it's time for
you to make some tough choices about who
you're going to surround yourself with